the movie begins in a lavish restaurant
where a man orders a large amount of
food after devouring all of it he takes
out a fly from his secret ring dips it
into his hot chocolate and places it on
the table he then calls the staff and
points at the dead fly on the table the
staff members immediately apologize for
the incident but the man starts berating
them in front of everyone as if he is
the victim of bad service worried about
the goodwill of the restaurant the
manager steps in and lets the man walk
away without paying for anything here we
get to know that the man's name is
clovis he is a professional con artist
and has never spent money on food
clothes or even shelter on another
occasion he along with his step-sister
lohane heads to a fancy clothing store
clovis orders his sister to go to the
changing room and tuck in as many
clothes as she can under her shirt then
he places one of the clothes into a
customer's bag after a while lohane
comes out and tells the storekeeper that
she didn't like any clothes and that she
will be leaving however there is one
last problem there is a tag in the
clothes and if anyone passes through the
door without paying the alarm starts
blaring this is where clovis idea comes
in as soon as the customer tries exiting
the door the sirens go off and the
storekeeper stops her taking this as the
perfect opportunity clovis and his
sister make a run for it while the alarm
is still blaring in this way the duo
manages to get free clothes let's not
pretend this movie isn't giving us all
ideas right now getting a free shelter
is even easier for clovis firstly he and
lohan pick the best hotel in the city
which has all the amenities one could
ask for he then approaches the
receptionist and provides a check
mentioning that he has just deposited
the sum but since it's a saturday the
money will only get credited on monday
the receptionist tries to argue that it
won't be possible to give them a room
without first receiving the money but
clovis starts blabbering about his
rights and finally convinces him this
way although he's rich himself he never
needs to pay for anything but it was not
always this way when he was a kid clovis
lived in a small brazilian city with his
parents he aspired to be a famous
painter one day but his dreams hit a
roadblock when his parents got separated
he then started living with his father
and rich mother-in-law but after just
one year his father became bored and
left after this clovis lived with his
rich mother-in-law and her new husband
but once again just after six months the
rich mother-in-law became tired and
filed for divorce in this way clovis
changed several families during his
teenage years and in one such family he
meets his stepsister lohane with whom he
gets along very well hey get your minds
out of the gutter cut to 15 years later
clovis has moved away from his family
and is now living all by himself in rio
de janeiro he has continued his passion
for painting but just in a different way
he paints realistic replicas of famous
paintings and sells them to a corrupt
senator who in turn sells them at 10
times the price because of all the
illicit dealings clovis has become a
vigorous speaker and has the ability to
convince anyone with his speech he has
also become a con artist and deceives
people every chance he gets however he
has one code which he always follows he
only cheats the rich in the next scene
clovis meets his friend tavino and
informs him that he is going to pull off
the biggest deception of his life he
then takes out some documents and
reveals that he is going to sell the
iconic christ the redeemer statue of rio
de janeiro expectedly tavino laughs at
the idea as it is virtually impossible
to sell a government property however
when clovis elaborates his plan in
detail he is bound to believe it
according to the plan clovis will pose
as a government real estate agent who
will then have all the necessary
permissions blueprints and the
valuations of the site furthermore
clovis has even created a fake website
with all the details for the deal the
first step is to contact a corrupt
businessman who is looking to buy a
piece of history for himself at a very
low price the final step is to convince
him that the deal is real and that's
where clovis's convincing skills come in
he will mention that the government is
looking to offload the structure as they
want to build something more productive
on the spot tavino is stunned to hear
all this but he lends his car to clovis
and wishes him all the best the next day
clovis contacts some businessmen and
sets up the meeting at a very crowded
beach surprisingly the men buy into the
story and they agree to the deal with
this clovis is handed a large briefcase
which contains millions of brazilian
reels elated he dances his way to
tovino's garage and gives him his share
of the money even at home clovis cannot
stop dancing and he sleeps with all the
money scattered across his bed however
his excitement doesn't last long as the
next morning the selling of christ the
redeemer is all over the news the police
have even made a sketch of him calling
him a fraudster scared clovis
immediately heads to divino's garage but
instead of asking for help he just
steals a car however when he returns
home to retrieve the money he finds that
the senator has tracked his location and
informed the cops about it furthermore
all his money is gone as clovis
calculates the severity of the situation
police sirens are heard in the
background hence he packs his remaining
belongings and immediately makes a run
for it just as he is about to escape he
runs into a woman who turns out to be
none other than his estranged stepsister
lohane clovis starts complaining that it
is the wrong time for her to show up as
he is having a very bad day but lohain
mentions that her day was even worse
following this the movie cuts back two
days where lohan is selling burgers in
her trailer although the money isn't
much she works really hard as she wants
to provide the best burgers in town
sadly one day two officers show up and
ask lohain for her business registration
papers when she mentions that she
doesn't have them the officers threaten
to take her trailer away lohane pleads
with them to let her be but the officers
just won't listen left with no other
options she bribes them with her entire
savings for the month and sends them
away however the very next day two
separate officers approach her and ask
for the papers when lohan tells them
that she has already sorted the issue
with their colleagues the officers
reveal that they have no colleagues
hearing this lohane realizes that she
has been conned to make matters worse
the officers take her trailer away
leaving her broke and alone hence with
nowhere to go she decides to meet the
only family member she has clovis back
in the present clovis urges lohan to get
in and speeds away from the place
without any explanation for the next few
hours slohan tries to initiate a
conversation but clovis remains silent
finally he stops at a secluded place and
finally reveals that the police are
after him he then takes her to a hotel
and produces yet another masterclass to
get them free entry later they head to
the fanciest store in town and get some
clothes for themselves using their usual
strategy following this clovis starts
plotting to rob a bank for this he
surveys the beach area with his
binoculars and spots a travel company
where a rich lady is talking to a sales
girl clovis knows that all the travel
companies in the area only trade in
checks so he sends lohane to capture a
photo of the rich lady's check so that
he can forge it at first lohan refuses
claiming that it's too risky but when
clovis promises to get her trailer back
she agrees in the next scene lohan
enters the store and strikes an awkward
conversation with the sales girl when
the rich woman whips out her check lohan
pretends to take a selfie and captures
the signature she then makes up an
excuse and heads outside after a while
when the rich woman is left clovis
enters the store pretending to be the
rich lady's assistant he mentions that
the last check has become obsolete due
to some reason so his mistress has sent
him with another one in reality the new
check is a forged one which belongs to a
fake bank account surprisingly the sales
girl buys the deception and returns him
the previous check without any question
after this clovis heads to the bank and
retrieves the large sum claiming that he
is the account holder's son with enough
money to keep them afloat for months
clovis and lohan decide to celebrate
that night however they are spotted by
the same sales girl who they had
deceived in the day normally clovis
always has a plan to get out of tough
situations but this time he simply
suggests that lohan run which she does
after a while the duo arrives at their
hotel gathers their belongings and sets
off in their car to another city the
next morning lohan and clovis stop at a
garage where clovis buys a vehicle for
his sister as promised however lohan is
not happy because she is getting a combi
instead of a trailer which is what she
had requested still she accepts it and
the two once again part ways with clovis
taking all of the money after just a few
minutes lohan starts missing her brother
and follows him she tells him that she
won't let him go unless he provides her
with a trailer enraged clovis steps on
the gas pedal and tries to leave lohan
behind but ends up blowing his car's
engine with no options left he is forced
to join lohane in her combi later as the
brosis duo drive through the countryside
they start reminiscing about their
childhood and they have a good time they
even sing some songs passionately and as
a result lohan gets distracted and
crashes into an oncoming poultry truck
that's one game of chicken she shouldn't
have played the duo survives the crash
with no injuries however they are forced
to flee without their money as the
police arrive at the scene almost
immediately
at night the tension in the air gets too
much as the two start arguing blaming
one another for the situation just then
lohane turns on the radio and a news
broadcast reveals that the authorities
are on the hunt for two con artists who
have scammed several people across the
city because of this lohan and clovis
are forced to stay inside their vehicle
hungry however being the smart guy that
he is clovis quickly comes up with a
plan to escape the city the next morning
they head to the local airport disguised
as doctors and pretend that they are
delivering a live heart to another city
expectedly the airport staff stops them
claiming that they need to have
reservations first but when clovis
mentions that the heart is required for
a vip transplant he agrees with this the
two board the flight and con their way
to another city sao paulo after they
arrive at the airport lohan goes to the
bathroom to freshen up leaving clovis
alone unfortunately some officers
recognize him and immediately arrest him
they then escort him away from the place
leaving lohan behind in the next scene
clovis is brought to the police station
and interrogated by the head
commissioner ricardo ricardo tells
clovis that he will be behind bars for
at least 20 years but the latter still
has an ace up his sleeve he tells the
commissioner that he knows a great deal
about other criminals and if given the
chance he will agree to a plea bargain
hearing this ricardo remembers that he
needs a promotion and accepts the deal
with this clovis starts revealing about
the senator and his ugly money
laundering business he even suggests a
plan to catch the senator red-handed the
next day ricardo brings clovis to his
temporary house where he can stay for a
week and execute the plan however he has
to wear an ankle bracelet so that he
can't run away again after ricardo
leaves clovis calls lohane and learns
that she has thrived in sao paulo using
his khan techniques he doesn't tell her
that he is under custody and instead
asks her to accompany him in one last
heist lohan is skeptical and she doesn't
want to get into trouble but clovis
eventually persuades her by promising to
provide her with half of the heist money
in the evening the two meet at clovis's
apartment and start discussing the plan
first of all clovis reveals his entire
history about how he used counterfeit
paintings and sell them to the senator
he then tells lohan that she has to do
exactly the same become a broker clovis
himself will forge a famous painting and
when it's ready lohan will have to
contact the senator and sell it at a
good price although lohan is scared she
agrees as she is in dire need of money
with this the two start their
preparations clovis begins painting a
famous piece while lohan practices her
communication skills a few days later
the painting is finally ready and clovis
even manages to contact the senator's
assistant roberto for the deal soon the
call arrives and lohane picks it up
hesitantly despite being nervous she
negotiates brilliantly and closes the
deal at 50 grand the next day she meets
up with roberto at a cemetery and
exchanges the painting for the money
while clovis is guiding her through a
walkie-talkie after the successful
mission the two head to a bar at night
and sing their hearts out now clovis has
all the money he wants but there is
still one thing he lacks freedom hence
in order to achieve it he has to get the
senator behind bars in the next scene an
auction is taking place in the city
where a lot of rich people including the
senator and his assistant are present
among the crowd ricardo is also seated
as an undercover while clovis is
disguised as a waiter soon the auction
begins and clovis painting is put up for
sale surprisingly the senator's
assistant roberto bids the highest and
buys the painting for himself here we
get to know that the senator is using
the paintings to convert his illegal
cash into white money as auctions don't
require sources of funds right then
clovis steps forward with another
replica of the painting and reveals to
everyone that both copies are fake he
also mentions that the senator is a
fraud who cheats people for his own good
taking this is the perfect opportunity
ricardo also rises from his seat and
tries to interrogate the senator however
the old man uses his power and influence
to simply brush off ricardo because of
this the plan fails and ricardo is left
with no choice but to take clovis in the
movie then fast forwards 18 months where
clovis is released from the prison he
narrates that brazil's law is so weak
that he was let out after just 18 months
despite his original sentence being 20
years outside he is greeted by lohane
and the two have an emotional reunion in
the last scene of the movie the
brother-sister duo has finally left
their criminal lives behind and they
have used the money to start a food
stall a lot of customers are present
which implies that their business is
booming the movie ends as the two
promise to be together for the rest of
their lives sus
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching